- It is incredibly hard to do anything.
This is a mistake.
(Joyful music)
Today, we're gonna get our nails did.
I feel like my masculinity
is pretty secure.
There's not much anyone can
say or do that can like,
harm my esteem.
- I'm probably a little bit
fragile, so, I think this is
actually gonna be a test for me.
- Here are two pairs of
gloves that you may put on,
if you ever feel uncomfortable or unsafe.
- You never know what'll
happen in the public.
You never know how
dangerous people could be
um, especially towards people
who are just wearing nails,
which seems ridiculous to me
but it could happen, so it's
something to watch out for
so, I'm happy I have these.
- Let's go get some nails done!
- [Alec] You want longer than that?
- [Ryann] Uh, yeah I want
them to be a little bit than.
I'm thinking like the Rihanna.
- That length seems fine to me.
- I'm so happy about this.
I think it is going to be fun.
Beyonce does it, and if it is good enough
for her, it is good enough for me.
(upbeat music)
- If you don't think you are being extra
with those on right now.
- I'm not extra, it's the right amount.
You wouldn't let them
be this length for you?
- Me? No.
I am more worried about like going out
to a bar, or going on on the weekend
to a club type setting
where there are like
really macho, masculine guys or something
that like are out there
drunk and ready to be mean.
I'm getting a little bit nervous,
because it is getting real right now.
- I just got my nails
done, I'm a little bit
more self conscious
about it then I thought.
I was like, this will be easy, but
the more I wear them, the more I am like,
oh, this is weird.
Honestly, I'm not adjusting as well
as I thought I would.
But we will see.
- I have been pretty nervous to show these
to everyone.
(laughter)
- Okay, just, let's seem them.
- What is even happening?
- Oh my god, that is crazy.
- I can not.
- [Ryann] What's wrong with them?
- First of all, they look like freaking
talons on a bird.
- I think they are fabulous.
- [Ryan] Thank you.
- I think they are very L.A.
- Do you like them?
Do you feel really feminine with them?
- It took me ten minutes
to get my pants unbuttoned
with these nails, and now,
I can't get them back up.
(laughter)
- I'm literally sitting here fumbling,
trying to grab an ear bud.
- I really couldn't type anything,
but the amount that has decreased my
productivity this week, has been
literally my least favorite thing.
- This is really hard and I hate
everything about the nails.
And I want to break them off right now,
if I could.
But I am determined to
make it through this week.
- I know he won't make
it through the week.
He cried last night about his pants.
I know he won't make through the week.
- I did.
- There was a girl who
actually sort of saw
my nails and just sort
of made this look like,
just like really disgusted and maybe
someone reacting negatively and it kind of
like made me question my
masculinity a little bit.
Through out my life, I have definitely
noticed that there have been pressures,
in terms of masculinity,
in that you want to avoid things
that might be feminine, so wearing nails
for a week is something that is definitely
a little uncomfortable.
- Today, at the gym, with my nails.
I have been getting a
couple of strange looks.
It is just weird to be in a place,
that is I guess hyper masculine,
and have such a feminine
considered object on my hands.
I didn't feel weird until here,
and now I'm like, I guess, maybe I
should have wore my gloves.
Because I am gay, when
I was in high school,
there were so many insecurities that I had
on top of being a teenager.
I think I just come to terms with it.
I don't think about my
masculinity as being
rigid or having to be a certain way.
- I thought that I was gonna have a few
people who made me feel
uncomfortable today,
and it just didn't happen.
I think it is just a
day to day experience,
based on like who sees them.
- This week has helped me understand a lot
more about people.
It is a decorative thing, and I feel like
anyone should be able to
do what they want to do.
What a week, it was a lot
harder than I thought.
Cause when we started,
I was like all about
the nails, I was like, yes,
this is gonna be fun.
Living my best life.
As you can see, I broke one.
- Kind of nervous to show people,
immediately got positive feed back,
and sort of got more comfortable with it
as the week went on.
I definitely felt masculinity issues,
and certain points of the week.
- There were definitely
moments that I felt
weird about having nails,
and when I think about it,
it literally doesn't make sense to feel
a type of way about these,
because every one has nails,
yes these are a little bit more ornate,
and they are a little bit more decorative,
but it is literally just
a way to express yourself.
- From this experience,
I think it has taught me
that were I once would
have maybe judged someone,
or like thought why would they do that,
I no longer think it's a big deal,
except I would sort of think good on them
for wearing those long nails.
I bet they can't type anymore.
(laughter)
- [Ryann] I bet they are
like, it's ten times harder.
(upbeat music)